Although Unreal Engine has many uses in film simulations
and real-time experiences, it's always fundamentally
been a game engine.
It allows users to create content,
then allow players to interact with it
and influence that content.
While there are many benefits to using Unreal Engine,
for the purposes of this course,
we're going to focus primarily
on the features and tools that directly relate
to video game development.
Small disclaimer, this slide does not actually
show the complete pipeline used in video games.
Rather, it's designed to help you understand that making video
games is an intricate and heavily interconnected process.
Most video games today made will
experience some kind of development, release,
patching, and possibly additional content release
through updates, patches, or DLC.
When it comes to developing your cutscenes pipeline,
the hope is that you will build systems and frameworks,
as well as your file and folder structures,
that allows you to reduce iteration times,
avoid asset dependency breakages,
and build a flexible framework that
will connect the player character, NPCs, world assets,
and your cinematic experiences.